people
are quitting their jobs in record
numbers but here's why it might not make
you any happier here's a cnbc story
millions of americans have been quitting
their jobs
over the past
year or two
and it's the most on record since the
government started recording labor
turnover since the year 2000 but here's
the question
will quitting your job actually make you
any happier here's what the article says
on cnbc experts say
maybe not as much as you think
especially in the long run if you don't
plan properly and this article basically
points to two major reasons
number one
people tend to adapt
back reversion to the mean if you've
ever heard that before so quitting your
job might make you happy
at first
but that feeling may not last long
says one psychology professor who has
been studying happiness for more than 30
years what a job by the way my job is to
study happiness by the way a little
small fact my friend founded this is at
the u.n
united nations founded the international
day of happiness it's in march by the
way maybe uh next march will bring them
back on to talk about happiness actually
the kingdom of bhutan
they don't that you know everyone every
country um is that next to wakanda
that's right near there um they judge
economic prosperity by gdp right gross
gross domestic product the kingdom of
bhutan has
ghp gross
happiness product how happy are there
people anyway a little small note right
there so the psychologist basically says
that when making changes we tend to
focus on the immediate change and how it
will make us feel but not what will
happen a month later right it's the i
want it now i want it now i want it now
mentality that millennials always get
their you know their chops busted for i
want it now but a month later they're
maybe like well
not so much not so much
all right so number one is people tend
to adapt back it's kind of like actually
our friend gerard's here he actually
showed us
um a clip of snl of adam sandler what's
up g and basically it was adam sandler
giving a spoof on snl about
romano tours
and
essentially his joke was like come to
romano tours we'll take you to italy
but here's what we can do and here's
what we can't do if you're a sad person
in new jersey
you're still going to be a sad person in
italy only in italy if you don't
if you don't like going hiking in the
states
you're not going to be a fan of hiking
in italy if you're got a drinking
problem in the states the reason that
you're drinking in italy is my so anyway
the point is you're going to tend to
adapt back to who you are no matter the
circumstances but here's number two
you can't run away from yourself
the article basically goes on and says
the reason for quitting a job may also
affect whether or not it will add to
your happiness so here's the question
i'm asking you guys at home
i'm breaking the fourth wall as our
friend like gee likes to say is it
something about you
or is it something about the job ask
yourself that is it something about you
or is it something about the job of why
you're quitting because if it's you
you will likely bring that problem to
your next job we take ourselves with us
to new new job basically the snl thing
where if you're unhappy in new jersey
just because you go on a tour of italy
you're gonna still be an unhappy person
correct so that's basically what it is
so
let me give a shout out to pbd real
quick you guys might have heard of pbd
patrick bett david he's the founder of
valuetainment he tells this story about
a person who goes from job to job to job
and how they always basically place
blame
on their boss or on their co-workers
well they didn't let me do this he
didn't understand that and he basically
says no
it's you
it's you if it's always somebody else's
fault it's all you're always fighting
with someone at your office if your boss
and you never get along
maybe it's not everybody else's fault
maybe it's you the hardest thing to do
is look in the mirror and be like
get it together buddy yeah we got it
together how many times you look in the
mirror and be like
you again
you i gotta
deal with you again nobody wants to face
the man in the mirror i believe michael
michael jackson once said yeah who was
he talking to
the man in the mirror for those of you
that say that i don't like karaoke i'll
do it right here just reminds me oh
brian's where you at o'brien's adam's
house god you guys killed it brian's
rules from ryan's role anyway so that's
the story that pb always says
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken